You might not be too impressed here.
So 2 to the power of N, 1.733 to the power of N, hmm, doesn't sound too good.
But there's 2 things to keep in mind here.
First of all, this is a worst case analysis,
so in practice we might be doing actually better.
And the second thing is even in a worst case analysis,
because we are dealing with exponential time,
this improvement here is actually huge.
So let's say that we're looking at an input of size 50.
Then 2 to the power of N assignments would be 10 to the power of 15,
about 1.13 times 10 to the power of 15.
So this is almost infeasible.
Maybe with a very, very, very, very, very powerful computer,
but you probably wouldn't want to do this
and probably also wouldn't want to do this for more than a single graph.
If, however, you have the smarter search tree, then you have 1.733 to the power of N,
which is 1.733 to the power of 50, and that is about 8.71 times 10 to 11.
And the difference here is a speed-up of over 1000.
That speed-up will become larger as N grows larger.
And the other thing is again that this down here is only a worst case analysis.
In many practical cases, the search tree will be much smaller
because first of all, as we saw, it's often the case that you assign more than just 2 vertices,
and in that case the tree doesn't become as high.
And also you can apply various other optimizations,
some of which we're soon going to talk about, to make the search tree even smaller,
both in practical cases and in the worst case.
Now, should Alice be happy about this?
Probably not yet because already for N equal to 50,
the running time of the algorithm here gets rather large.
So if she is solving the problem for a telecommunications network
with, say, 500 vertices, it will still be out of the question to find an optimal solution
using the search tree.
But of course there's a little hope already
because we haven't really fully explored search trees yet.
Maybe it's going to get even better for her.
But before we continue helping Alice, let's have a look at Bob and Carol
and see if can apply smart search trees also for their problems: independent set and clique.